on va les voir certains parents qui sont
prêtes à tout pour faire le buzz dans
les grandes gueules de rmc story on a
découvert une vidéo de deux enfants
instrumentalisé on va dire à des fins
politiques allant jusqu'à proférer des
insultes envers le président de la
république
je pense que ça va vous faire réagir on
regarde et on s'en parle juste après on
a des sondages aujourd'hui qui commença
à montrer le degré de haine qui anime
les réseaux sociaux ce qui est assez
inquiétant et alors on a des
illustrations qui je vous jure vous font
tomber les bras aux vous demande si vous
devez encore croire en l'homme et en la
femme
la preuve avec cette vidéo tournée par
des parents qui demandent à leurs
enfants d'insulter le président de la
république et son épouse
voilà ce que ça donne non mais des fois
il faut alors le public j'entends réagi
alors évidemment on parle pas des gels
et je ne parle pas du fond évidemment
voilà ça c'est pas du tout le sujet le
sujet c'est ses parents qui mettent en
scène des enfants alors pour mettre en
avant leurs idées lors que ce soit celle
ci ou d'autres un peu importe là en
l'occurrence avec du un vocabulaire qui
est quand même peu cher petit peu châtié
on va dire quelles sont vos réactions
caroline super choqué quand je vois le
contenu et je me dis que rien ne va
c'est vulgaire on doit pas mêler les
enfants à la raison d'un mollet ni
qu'ils sont tout petits on le voit très
bien c'est rien ne va mais en même temps
moi je ne pense pas du tout que ce soit
pour faire du buzz
je ne pense pas du tout que ce soit mise
en scène je pense qu'il ya des familles
où ça se passe comme ça et que ça fait
partie d'un système éducatif de dire on
peut pas blairer macron le président etc
c'est comme on va acheter du pain de la
baguette et mettre mes films et ses
enfants dans cette situation là ça s'est
passé pas ce qui me choque c'est pas
tellement qu'ils instrumentalisent vous
comme vous dites leurs enfants ce qui me
choque c'est effectivement la haine que
des enfants peuvent transmettre à leur
départ en valeur à leurs enfants sans
forcément s'en rendre compte et qu'on
retrouve ensuite dans les cours de récré
etc mais pour moi c'est pas du buzz
d'accord l'arrêt
série c'est la réalité jimmy alors bien
sûr c'est scandaleux bien sûr que ça
choque tout le monde mais si on veut
essayer de comprendre comprendre ce
n'est pas excuser ce n'est pas légitime
ou illégitime et dire que c'était rien
je pense qu on est dans un monde où on
cherche la culture du buzz de faire une
vidéo virale qui n'a pas radical inverse
at elle fait je pense que c'était fait
exprès c'est calculé je pense que sans
les réseaux sociaux dont 100 twitter
facebook instagram ses parents
n'auraient jamais fait ça et bien sûr
que ça choque et je pense que c'est
simplement la recherche de la gloire de
la vidéo qui fait mouche à le dire que
c'est symptomatique d'une époque cesse
et vous mettez dans le même panier par
exemple ces vidéos ont fait pleurer un
enfant pour le pur pour faire pour faire
marrer les gens parce que ils n'arrivent
pas à manger sa glace aux autres pour
vous c'est dans le même esprit c'est là
une petite vidéo virale qui va faire
parler qui a fait rire et on oublie que
derrière on expose nos enfants on oublie
que derrière ces propos sont très
violents et peut-être que désormais les
parents lorsqu'il regarde cette vidéo
ils disent ah ouais vraiment on a
déconné on était pris sur le moment on
s'est dit qu'on va faire une blague elle
est très mauvaise et c'est intolérable
un jeune je ne justifie pas mais je
pense que notre mode de vie peut
expliquer qu'on en arrive là désormais
en 2018 a très bien non mais là je vous
trouve très mesuré tous les deux ans
pardon mais moi j'ai utilisé des termes
crus il faut que l'aide sociale à
l'enfance place ces deux camps mais ils
sont en danger ça nous avantage et rama
je suis désolé je n'exagère pas bien de
placer les enfants de décès de cette
dame j'entends rigoler dans le public
mais c'est très sérieuse que j'ai c'est
à dire que je veux ça veut dire pour
vous c'est une vie est en danger les en
fait parce que j'ai enfoncé une porte
ouverte mais le rôle des parents c'est
quoi ces d'inculquer les valeurs de
respect alors je pense que tout est
choquant dans cette vidéo c'est à dire
qu on les incite à s'exprimer dans des
termes absolument immonde alors qu'on
devrait plutôt leur apprendre la
politesse ont leur lot on les
instrumentalise aussi en véhiculant des
idées politiques qu'ils sont tout la
série sur le fameux l'aide des idées
politiques c'est pas c'est pas le
fondeur on n'est vraiment pas loin de la
maltraitance sur ce qu'il a donc annoncé
pas c'est pas exagérer les uns donné la
maltraitance de deux mètres des enfants
non dans des situations comme ça et
ensuite les expose je comprends que
l'avenir soit très choquée je pense qu
on l'est tous et tout le public l'est
aussi mais il faut quand même
relativiser un petit peu damien je pense
que tu vas très très loin évidemment que
je trouve ça scandaleux
évidemment que la politique c'est pas un
truc d'enfants c'est comme quand on
voyait les gamins qui était traîné à la
manif pour tous alors qu'ils avaient
quatre cinq ans et que savait pas du
tout ce qu'ils avaient et ce qu'il
faisait là mais de là à prayssas non
messieurs ampleur non non non c'est
différent pour le manifeste
pour tous on peut imaginer que l'enfant
était au centre du problème puisqu'il
était question de gpa de paiement avec
et sur ma y avait quand même une
histoire avec un enfant là la loi macron
etc enfin toutes les protections sur
notre débat qui est pas sur le fond non
et gilet jaune et autres moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la mise en avant d'un
enfant sur des réseaux sociaux avec des
propos qui peuvent choquer il est chaque
dans la promo des choses comme ça et
cette mise en avant d'un enfant qui a 5
ans qui comprend visiblement pas ce
qu'ils racontent
elle a parlé de maltraitance et dire
qu'il faut appeler l'aide sociale à
l'enfance j'aimerais qu'on s'occupe des
enfants qui sont j'ai pas l'air vraiment
mal traités parce que je savais qu'ils
sont victimes de pédophilie les enfants
qui sont tabassés toute l'année des
enfants qu'on maltraite d'autres façons
on prive d'aliments qu'on va mettre dans
l'arrivée dans des conditions insalubres
sur la je vais pas dire ok bien sympa
alors leur vie est belle mais néanmoins
c'est une très très très très mauvaise
publicité effectivement c'est très près
nous est plus ça va c'est vraiment
horrible mais quand même il faut
peut-être relativiser je pense que nous
d'ailleurs ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag sécu dlt je rappelle qu'on est
en direct et qu'on débat tous ensemble
et ça m'intéresse aussi là réellement
parce que je vois que il ya des bémols
ya des interrogations et cetera dites
moi ce que vous en pensez sur ces vidéos
et pas forcément que celle ci met en
tout cas ces vidéos de parents prêts à
tout éventuellement comme dit jimmy pour
faire le buzz ou caroline qui dit
simplement parce qu'ils ont envie de
mettre en avant des idées voilà c'est
intéressant de savoir ce que vous en
pensez allez en parler
rajoute juste que damien est un gros
ringard été carrément grave ce que tu
dis mon chat je t'aime beaucoup mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas tout confondre
non plus je dirai jamais assez choqué
droite a permis un 10-2 de placer ses
angles perchoc en or mais c'est choquant
car aux lignes d'eau pour sa médecine h
entre -10 et des idées politiques qu'ils
véhiculent et qu'ils transmettent à leur
enfant simplement hymne aux gros mangent
machin se payer des politiques en
attente
[Applaudissements]
non mais on a compris propos global
voilà